we covered the first three steps
next we'll talk about the feature
selection step
in the feature selection step we have
talked about how construct features
using patient event sequences from the
hrc data
in particular we construct feature from
raw data in the observation window
if we look closely at the observation
window we see event sequence data
which are corresponding to different
types of clinical events
for example diagnosis symptoms
medications
patient demographics lab results and
vital signs
we can construct features from all those
events
however not all the events are relevant
for predicting a specific
target the goal of feature selection is
to find the truly predictive features to
be included in the model
for example here are two patient charts
we can see some features such as
demographics including age
race and gender and vital signs such as
blood pressures
and diagnosis such as diabetes and
hypertension
however in reality this patient chart is
not that simple
in fact we can construct a long list of
features over twenty thousand features
from a typical ehr data set not all of
this are relevant for predicting a
target
we need to select the ones that are
relevant to the target condition
for example if we want to predict heart
failure maybe those yellow features are
relevant
however for a different condition such
as diabetes
maybe those purple features are relevant
the goal of features selections
is to identify those predictive features